he's CSN New England's Tom Curren how
you doing there Tom great what's going
on is it great in Boston right now tom
is it really great a lot of
hand-wringing okay and as you know it's
usually people don't go well they get
some work to do it well these guys suck
right but they do have some work to do
in a way that I did not see coming and
and and and then there's also this part
of it Tom is that we're in the day and
age where an michael Lombardi he's gonna
be on the show
on Wednesdays during the football season
and he knows the Patriots and Bella
checks mind very simply very well as
well he says he still thinks that the
league should consider the first two
weeks of the regular season like an
extension of the preseason they're still
working on stuff what to the page what
do you take out of last night's game
against the Chiefs Tom I agree
wholeheartedly with Micah and have felt
that way for a while you don't know
really know what teams are even that I
tried to do until after Columbus Day but
the Patriots first off I think
offensively it wasn't as bad as it
looked it was interesting to hear Tom
Brady and Nate solder and Doron Hartmann
all lament the lack of energy intensity
and competitiveness that the team
exhibited but offensively I think that
goes to some of the fourth downs they
weren't able to convert and the
outgrowth there being look we weren't
tough enough but I also look at the
absence of Julian Edelman in so many
different ways one if he's out there you
have an opportunity on fourth and one a
third and one to have him run one of
those quick option routes where he
shakes people who's or at least draw
attention instead the Patriots were kind
of in a bunch formation and a bunched up
formation and ran into a 10-man front
and didn't get it
Edelman also they didn't even challenge
the middle of the field rich and with
Edelman they can do that because he can
get separation even if it's cluttered
Hogan's not that kind of player he had
one catch for eight yards Gronk had two
catches for 33 and on both of them he
was pretty well covered as much as
people resist the idea of it Edelman
leads to Gronk Gronk doesn't lead to
Edelman because Edelman draws so much
attention that eventually Gronkowski
profit
from it there's no one getting
separation they don't have to send a
second guy at anyone except for cooks
who's a perimeter guy anyway and they
couldn't get it to him too much in the
middle so I think those were huge parts
plus that intensity that Edelman brings
he's kind of an enforcer type they'll
figure it out on offense but rich
defense it's it really was astonishing
to see those explosive plays wasn't it
yeah it was but it's also a couple two
young kids I mean in Hill and hunt that
have incredible speed and I'm I'm
thinking that the Patriots are gonna see
that quite a bit this year from a lot of
young guys that's part of the reason why
they went and got Brandon cooks I mean
nobody can run with him they know that
that's the way this league is going is
with speed um so before we get to the
defense though and and leave the offense
tamo I do want to just touch on to use
the phrase the famous Pitino phrase you
know Julian Edelman is not walking
through that door so how do they fix it
on offense do they go with more of the
running backs to create more matchup
problems yeah use those guys in the
middle of fields I think that's exactly
what they need to do when you saw James
White on the field a little bit more
toward the end of the game and he was
trying to get out there into those
option routes where it would shake loose
but they're gonna have to start doing
that but see Edelman is just unique in
terms of the speed with which he gets
open and that's the interesting thing
with Brady is we all understand how
unbelievably is in his resume but the
skills that he has which is brain
accuracy velocity on short area throws
that's what the offense is built around
it's not built around him throwing
outside on 20-yard comebacks and back
shoulder throws when when a guy is well
covered that's that's not what the whole
thing is predicated on so it puts him in
a position where he's throwing lower
percentage passes that he would prefer
not to throw he wants to fill the
running catch stuff until they figure
out how they're gonna address that or
they improve on the outside just with
reps it's going to be a hard slugs well
in terms of and then one last thing
because you're hitting
put up 28.8 ill whatever no no they they
they they did and they were ahead after
3/4 which normally means that's all she
wrote in Foxboro but we're all in the
national media for sure looking for the
signs of Brady aging now that he's 40
because that's a number it's not like
when he was 39 he's close enough to 40
but looking for the the signs and I'm
wondering why didn't they do the
quarterback sneak stuff with him on
those short yardage situations last
night is that a signal that the Patriots
don't want to put a forty-year-old
in that situation when he's the best in
those situations Tom I'd have to see it
more before I would conclude that on the
second drive where they had after that
turnover the fourth and one from the I
believe it was the the 10 I think that
was a all right let's let's do what
we're supposed to do it's 2017 we're a
new team let's go pick up a hard yard
here and create our identity a little
bit and they got stuffed so I'd have to
see it happen more frequently for me to
conclude that they don't want to do that
I think Brady more often on those sneaks
he's not going into a bunched front he's
he's able to find a place you know to
burrow through but you know it's
certainly a much more valid question in
terms of Brady and being 40 than saying
well he missed some throws is is that
the Aged no it's things like you're
mentioning there where you don't want to
put him in harm's way or he didn't
audible to it but I think I'd need to
see more of it happening to conclude
that Tom Caron here in the Honda inside
a report from CSN New England all right
so then let's address the defense what
in the world is the fix in that locker
room Tom I don't think so especially
with Dante Hightower suffering that knee
injury we still don't need to know the
extent of it he didn't return he was on
the sidelines after getting his right
knee caved but he's a guy who he's gonna
miss time most likely I would think even
though it's a 10-day layoff just
the way it looked and it's a [ __ ] he's
gonna have to deal with that all season
long now not what we would call a quick
healer and we've seen in the past he's
their most important front 7 player
there they played that style last night
rich of putting four safeties on the
field of times often having five and six
defensive backs up there having safeties
that the linebacker spots Jourdan
Richards was up there for a ton of time
and they have a skinny guy cashes Marsh
who was playing on the outside a
defensive end and Travis Kelce said
quite plainly I don't think that they
respected Alex Smith's arm and I don't
think that they respected our running
game and I don't know if it was that I
think it was just that they think that's
the best way to go against speed has put
speed on the field but Smith did a great
job he put the ball where he needed to
be in space to players and they did
damage with it so I guess when it's all
said and done an stumble poll question
Brockman I mean it is I know on what
your answer is gonna be Tom but I'm
gonna ask it to you anyway
go for it Chris yeah Tom are the
Patriots on to New Orleans or done as a
Super Bowl contender do you think Tom I
think they are absolutely on to New
Orleans let's see where they are honest
to god let's see where they are just a
couple check points
I remember saying mr. Brady after they
lost to Kansas City in week 4 2014 in in
a similar fashion explosive plays they
got run over they missed tackles they
look stupid both sides of the ball and
he had finished his press conference and
I was in the locker room because I knew
he'd be walking back through there and I
said tough crowd and he just kind of
cruise past me they smile he goes yep
talk to me in November meaning give it a
month give it some time it's not gonna
be as bad then as it looked tonight and
I think that's the same result but that
was a team and a defense it had I hate
to say it but they had Chandler Jones it
had you know Dante Hightower it had
Jamie Collins this team is still got to
establish what
it's identity is going to be because
there's a lot of new faces on defense
but for what think of it by the way I
wouldn't be stunned at all if he isn't
real back in before too long yeah we
were Brock when you brought that up
right like do you think do you think
they give him a call and say Rob you
want to rethink this he was on our air
the other night on CSN and he was asked
would you uh would you come back and he
said I'm not going to close the door on
it well look Taylor last year but
stability right now man I mean well look
if Brady's talking about digging deeper
right and he's talking about some people
in that locker room who might not be
they're new to the Patriot Way and they
haven't figured it out yet
I mean Ning kovitch is one of those guys
is gonna walk around out locker room and
tell him everyone what the hell's going
on what time it is right Tom yeah you
know little things like Chris Long not
being there he was in one year a pretty
good leader he wasn't incredibly
productive but he got his job done and
he understood what he was supposed to do
he wasn't perfect by any stretch but you
know dude there are some guys who went
out the door who had some ability now
and again they want to get some crap
offenses last year throughout the year
they benefited from that and they were
able to move into a level of competency
but that was because they could out
score people - they're gonna have to fix
the Edelman question and they're gonna
have to hang on for a while on defense I
think Tom love chatting let me know when
I call your podcast okay
reach out I definitely will thank you
buddy you gotta it's Tom Curren CSN New
England Honda insider for the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy